Oh
my name is Jody Zetas and Nick Thompson
Alan and I are the two associate organ
curators at Yale and here at Yale we
look after a total of 15 pipe organs
some of them by some of the best
builders in the country if not the world
but the crown jewel of these instruments
is the one behind me the great Newberry
memorial organ here in Woolsey Hall all
of the sounds in this organ are produced
by air pressure there are no
electronically enhanced sounds or
digital sounds of any kind and it just
reflects on how clever organ builders
have been to learn new and strange ways
to shove air through organ pipes this
one has over 12,000 pipes no two of
those pipes are alike these wonderful
machines are the 19:15 Spencer turbines
that supply the organ with air pressure
and they generate enough pressure to
blow all 12,000 pipes when necessary the
air pressure is delivered to the series
of wind trunks I come out and go over
heads while bellows
and that bellows is actually a regulator
which controls the air pressure that the
organ works upon organ builders choose
the material on the shape of the pipe
depending on the kind of sound they want
to generate for example these narrow
skinny pipes are called string pipes
they just sit in the hole and they
produce a sound which is a rather sounds
like a string whereas the equivalent
pipes these flutes for example have an
entirely different sound
behind these doors is a treasure trove
of technology I'm very proud about this
is something you will not see anywhere
else in the world anymore this is the
1928 remote combination action for the
organ it was very sophisticated
technology of its time it's the space
shot of its period and basically the
combinations that the organist chooses
to recall what the push buttons are
stored down here on what amounts to an
electro pneumatic computer this is a
series of unions for the wiring of the
organ and all the names of the stops
were carefully written here in ink back
in 1915 I like looking at it because
everything here is original and you see
the care that was exercised in the
wiring of the organ
these wires are double cotton covered
wires and they were shellac for
protection
they'll be here a hundred years from now
in this mysterious door is the back of
the organ console and when necessary I
can climb out there and make repairs to
the organ console without having to pull
it away from the stage some of the pipes
are as tall as a four-story house others
are the size of a swizzle stick some of
them are extremely soft in nature and
delicate and make you think that there
are angels floating in the ceiling other
sounds are so powerful that they are
overwhelming and cascades of sound
engulf the listeners in this hall it's a
sound that I've never grown tired of